now you and i both went to a bunch of
the hawks playoffs games we were very
excited our team made it to the eastern
conference finals finally yes and we
gonna do it again oh yeah i know when
the hawks played the sixers you bet some
money with was it meek or michael rubin
meek meet me you came back with michael
rubin yeah i mean he's just
that's a billionaire
so how much did you win
i won ten thousand no twenty thousand
twenty thousand
what's the most you've bet on any
sporting event
um
[Music]
let me see
oh 50 000 with um drake georgia gang
georgia
was it georgia
oklahoma i think it was georgia oklahoma
rose bowl and then we came back
with georgia alabama
and our loss
we broke even
okay yeah we broke even but it was
that was a good one i also remember
hearing that i guess on tour you all
played i don't know it was one-on-one or
like five on five whatever but you won
that yeah we played five on five
the whole tour was we were supposed to
play because because the the tour was
set up like a nba season i think it was
like 80 dates or something like that so
every every in every spot we had like a
court book
we started out playing the game we got
so intense that we didn't even play no
more the whole the whole tour
he got too intense we all had fun over
here yeah that was that was the best
tour i've ever been on that was the most
time i fun fun time i had in my life yes
it was
you can't even explain it like
basketball with my dogs
80 days
hitting the road playing the best music
we played we all got hits together we
kept coming out on his set
doing other songs and
doing all the songs we got it was just
organic it felt real good yeah and i
know you made one of the half court
shots oh yeah yeah and i drake was
supposed to pay you for it but last i
heard he had never paid did he end up
paying for not making it no no no i
ain't good i ain't get straight i think
we no he did give me ten thousand okay
he did give me ten thousand on that yes
he did he paid yeah you did an interview
with angie and i remember he was late he
had it he was like i was on them for a
minute so yeah i was on about my little
10.